ja ganz schön viel los gewesen diese
woche ein mysteriöses leuchten kommt aus
hong kongs gewässern
wissenschaftler können ein ipad kochen
und eine drohne soll auf dem mars
fliegen diese und noch mehr spannende
themen gibt es jetzt bei den keks um top
five - mysteriöses leuchten viele
gewässer in der nähe von hongkong
leuchten nachts blau seit einiger zeit
taucht dieses phänomen immer häufiger in
der nähe der metropole auf
umweltschützer schlagen nun alarm die
erhöhte umweltverschmutzung im
asiatischen raum hat zur folge dass sich
kleine meeres leucht tierchen gebildet
haben daran einmal zwei millimeter groß
sind die wasserlebewesen durch die
wasserverschmutzung können sich die
tierchen unglaublich schnell vermehren
so dass inzwischen ganze uferbereiche
bläulich schimmern die tatsache dass
sich die organismen von algen ernähren
ist auch nicht hilfreich denn beides
führt zu weniger sauerstoff im wasser
die leuchtenden meerestiere stellen also
eine gefahr für das ökosystem dar
laut den umwelt forschern sind die
organismen zwar für den menschen direkt
nicht gefährlich allerdings stehen sie
zu dem ohnehin schon großen
abwasserproblem in asien bei mars rover
soll partner bekommen über den mars
rover curiosity berichten wir hier bei
pixum ja häufig der roboter bringt ja
auch ungeheuer viele interessante dinge
über den mars in erfahrung allerdings
hat er ein klitzekleines problem mehr
ist immer nur sehr langsam unterwegs mit
höchstens vier zentimetern pro sekunde
kann er zwar unglaublich viel technik
mit sich führen ist aber seit seiner
landung im august 2012
gerade einmal zwölf kilometer von seinem
startpunkt weg gekommen um die mars
oberfläche besser zu verstehen und um zu
entscheiden wohin man curiosity in
zukunft schicken soll
wie die nasa nun eine drohne auf dem
mars schießen lassen
der helikopter den die nasa im moment
plan soll gerade einmal ein kilogramm
schwer sein
trotzdem haben seine flügel eine
spannweite von über einem meter das ist
auch richtig denn obwohl auf dem mars
nur ein drittel der gravitationskraft
der erde wirkt ist fliegen auf dem war
sehr schwierig das problem ist die
atmosphäre sie hat nur 0 6 prozent der
dichte wie unsere atmosphäre auf der
erde
um trotzdem den nötigen auftrieb zu
generieren sollen die mutter blätter mit
über 40 umdrehungen pro sekunde
wenn der helikopter erst einmal auf dem
mars ist soll er in zwei bis drei
minuten einen halben kilometer
zurücklegen und dabei frühzeitig
hindernisse für kohli city oder andere
mars-rover erkennen erstes 3d hirn
kopiert ein großes ziel der
stammzellenforschung ist es gewebe für
menschen entstehen zu lassen dann wenn
sie es brauchen
wenn ein organ ausfällt oder verletzt
wurde müssen viele menschen teilweise
jahrelang auf ein spenderorgan warten
verschwendete lebenszeit eine der
größten hürden dieser technik war es
stammzellen dreidimensional wachsen zu
lassen und zwar ganz besonders wenn es
um neuronale verbindungen geht denn
diese müssen nicht nur sehr speziell
aufgebaut sondern auch noch miteinander
verbunden werden einen riesigen erfolg
haben und japanische wissenschaftler
eingefahren als sie das weltweit erste
3d gehirngewebe mit stammzellen
nachwachsen lassen konnten
der prozesses wachsen dauerte über 15
wochen dabei wuchs zuerst das mittelhirn
während das gewebe später auch die
hirnrinde bildete die forscher benutzten
für ihr labor gehirn embryonale
stammzellen und diverse
wachstumsbeschleuniger auch wenn die
technik noch sehr lange erforscht und
verbessert werden muss wird das ganze
projekt natürlich ungemein viele fragen
auf wenn man ein gehirn kopiert wer bin
ich dann wenn ich dieses gehirn habe und
wenn mir eine exakte kopie meines
gehirns eingepflanzt wird bin ich dann
immer noch ich diese spannenden fragen
werde ich in der nächsten folge von
krieg zum tanzen fiction am dienstag
beantworten also vergesst nicht vorbei
zu schauen wissenschaftler in kochen 1 1
man nehme ein ei kochen das wasser an
fünf minuten zeit das ergebnis ist ein
leckeres frühstück sei aber wer nach dem
kochen doch lieber ein spiegelei gehabt
hätte der schaut in die röhre
bis jetzt denn wissenschaftlern ist es
nun gelungen dieses große problem zu
lösen und große teile von gewöhnlichen
frühstückseier nach dem kochen wieder zu
entkommen
jetzt denkt dass die wissenschaftler
sich einen kleinen scherz erlaubt haben
und die methode keinen praktischen
nutzen hätte der täuscht sich gewaltig
denn die methode könnte viele neue
einsichten auf der ebene der
krebsforschung bringen außerdem sind
sich die wissenschaftler sicher dass die
technik eine schnellere und günstigere
alternative bietet antikörper
herzustellen die in der krebs
immuntherapie eingesetzt werden um die
eier wieder in ihren normalzustand
zu versetzen benutzten die
wissenschaftler eine chemikalien namens
kohlensäure die amid diese organische
verbindung wird von vielen lebewesen als
urin ausgeschieden
spätestens nach dieser info werden ob
die meisten von euch darauf verzichten
ein frühstücksei wieder zu entkommen
um daraus spiegelei zu machen guten
appetit
erste auswertung der mission rosetta die
forscher der mission rosetta sind eifrig
dabei die ersten daten der sonne viel
eher auszuwerten
der komet tschurjumow gerasimenko auf
dem die sonne letzten november gelandet
ist gehört zu den dunkelsten objekten
unserem sonnensystem
eine mögliche ursache hierfür ist eine
zusammensetzung der oberfläche aus
dunklem materialien wie zum beispiel
eisen sulfiden oder silikaten an der
oberfläche befindet sich außerdem sehr
wenig bis gar kein wasser als trotzdem
sind sich die forscher sehr sicher dass
sich welches im inneren des kometen
befindet die spannendste entdeckung
könnte die von organischen
kohlenwasserstoffverbindungen sein
sie lassen darauf schließen dass der
komet von außerhalb unseres
sonnensystems stammt nur dort lassen
sich die nötigen uv strahlen bei
niedriger temperatur finden die nötig
sind um solche verbindungen entstehen zu
lassen die sonde hat auch den
kometenschweif untersuchen können dabei
allerdings große schwankungen in der
zusammensetzung festgestellt die sich
die forscher nicht erklären können und
auch die gänsehaut ähnliche struktur auf
der oberfläche bleibt ein mysterium
nach wie vor ist die entstehung des
kometen ungewiss turiaf gerasimenko gibt
den wissenschaftlern weitere spannende
rätsel auf über die wir hier bei pixum
natürlich berichten werden wer sich über
die mission rosetta informieren will
findet in diesem video alle wichtigen
infos zum black und block offen zur app
die zwei mal hier unten
alle links zu den angesprochenen themen
sind natürlich auch in der video
beschreibung zum schluss noch ein
hinweis in eigener sache ich mache hier
natürlich weiter clixoom ist meine
leidenschaft und es macht unglaublich
spaß hier videos zu machen in zukunft
fertig sogar noch mehr zeit für den
kanal haben und es wird mehr geben denn
cedrick hat einen super tollen job
gemacht wird hier auch eine rubrik
bekommen und meine frage an euch worüber
soll er videos machen schreibt es in die
kommentare ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran